maintenant les doyon c'est l'interview
par amour dans le bush mardi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
bientôt par amour seriez vous prête à
sacrifier vos ambitions professionnelles
oui ah pardon excusez moi
ça dépend ouais ça dépend ça dépendra
parce que si quelqu'un t'aime
logiquement pour quoi il demanderait de
sacrifier ton travail
moi ça a été le même problème avec ma
copine et moi j'adore me faire plein de
nanas et elle voulait que j'arrête
lt mais pas assez mais pas assez pour
pour accepter ça tu es obligé de se
séparer
oui j'avais pas le fait d'amour par un
mot à ce que vous accepteriez de vous
faire refaire le nez
même si le mec cette folle de lui vous
dit on attend c'est encore pire moment
premièrement je le ferai pas parce que
par amour qui demande sa refaire tout
cas rien de plus insultant j'en écoute
je t'aime mais si tu veux qu'on reste
ensemble surfer et et non moi je veux
rien de faire offert parce que j'aurai
les boules par rapport à mes parents
battu par tous temps les autres je vais
faire ça par amour seriez vous prête à
faire ou ne pas faire d'enfant est ce
qu'ils n'en veut pas du tout du tout du
tout oui voilà vaches ouais non ça me
ferait peur ça me ferait peur moi non
moi je veux des enfants
ensuite par amo est ce que vous seriez
prête à héberger ses parents ouais
j'aime bien aussi l'amant d'accord
est-ce que alors ça c'est beaucoup plus
grave par amour est ce que vous seriez
prête à l'aider à cacher le corps de
quelqu'un qu'il vient de tuer
ouais je crois j'aimerais ça
mais
même si je n'aime pas par amour ou
est-ce que vous accepteriez qu'il est
une maîtresse
s'il m'est déjà arrivé mais c'est dans
des circonstances où toi ça te fait pas
de mal donc toi tu certainement tu t'en
fous donc c'est pas vraiment là moi
c'est mais si vraiment il est le grand
amour vous auriez du mal à ce qu'il est
mais je suis vachement je suis pas non
non non je pourrais pas supporter de
titres et par amour est ce que vous
seriez prête à vivre à trois c'est pas
pareil
vous avez 3 à une intrigue d'abord avec
une autre fille après qu'un garçon ouais
ouais ouais avec une autre fille
d'accord ouais un autre garçon ouais
super
évidemment on sent que j'avais une
éducation à la route heures ce qui n'est
pas le cas toutes les filles alors est
ce que vous seriez prête par amour à
aller le samedi dans un club échangiste
tous les samedis oui on peut le dire
n'ont pas tous les samedis un samedi sur
deux je suis jamais allé donc je crois
que ça m'intrigue ray pas mal une une
première fois juste pour voir mais ça me
fait toujours flipper parce que je sais
que tu peux pas y aller si tu veux pas
participer pas mal à bon non parce que
ces deux mythes
parce que c'est vrai que c'est une
ambiance futur c'est terriblement
malsain en même temps tu te demande tu
vois si les gens ils parlent avant ou
pas parce qu'ils n'ont même pas bons les
discussions c'est toujours à peu près la
même ces deux cours jamais les magasins
but non par amour
est ce que vous seriez prête à devenir
son esclave sexuelle ça défie ce qui
fait que je sais pas si c'est drôle oui
tu sais que je suis comique
ça s'appelle l'interview par amour et
vous savez que dans la bouche
en à bouche marc pendant le single
[Musique]
il ya deux connards de rebelles ce soir
heureusement que le cadreur et
d'assistés qui bouge la caméra parce que
donc par amour est ce que vous seriez
prête à sacrifier vos ambitions
professionnelles pour l'amour le vrai
amour et vous y croyez toujours vrai
amour heureusement heureusement si la
ville de répondant
madame la baronne de répondre alors
est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à refuser un film avec
steven spielberg
bien sûr pour l'amour pour tous pour
simone si votre fiancée vous dis je
refuse que tu tournes avec vous et c'est
exactement la théorie de madame la
baronne qui dit quand on aime quelqu'un
on a de la chance ce soir là deux femmes
très très gros principe
j'espère que les autres en prendront des
intelligences et où vous avez raison en
baronne est ce que par amour vous
retourneriez vivre en république tchèque
toute la technologie
je crois que si on trouve l'amour et
nous ramène en bout du monde d'accord
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
vous faire refaire les seins
sinon ça sera pas un mot encore ce n'est
pas un vrai amour un type qui
demanderait une période où gobain se
faire les choses soient un connard
devrait faire un vrai amour est-ce que
par amour vous seriez prête à ne pas
faire d'enfant ça c'est difficile
difficile à un mec qui vous dit je
t'aime on se marie mais moi je déteste
les enfants j'en veux pas c'est pas
possible c'est lé fruit de l'amour c'est
automatique c'est naturel que ça vienne
est-ce que par amour vous aideriez votre
votre homme a caché le corps de
quelqu'un qu'il vient de tuer et vous
aussi oui ouais mais vous préférez
mais oui après j'ai écrit un livre
là-dessus l'avantagé la littérature
c'est tout semble avoir un sens
subitement alors ça c'est une question
importante c'est la question de clotilde
courau clotilde courau qui est une jeune
actrice très talentueuse d'ailleurs nous
a dit que par amour quand elle était
plus jeune elle embrasse et 100 fois de
suite les chaussettes sales de son
fiancé c'est possible vous le feriez
vous vous aussi à vous non non non non
des limites vous avez jamais vu c'est
pas le pire faut dire à nadine vous avez
jamais vécu que le batteur de bonnes
notes
non non avec boris bien ouais c'est vrai
nom nadine
devait avoir 25 ans et j'en avais 16 des
20 years ago va est par amour vous
accepteriez que votre fiancée et une
maîtresse j'aurais mal à supporter
j'aurais j'aurais très mal oui mais si
vous voulez mais vraiment voulais qu'il
soit heureux mais c'est d'éduquer la
france entière d'habitude c'est
compliqué 6 il amène sa maîtresse et que
vous faites un truc à 3 à st pas lasser
mais ça c'est ça n'est pas besoin d'être
assistées après on fait passer sur le
point d'être huit ans elle a pas besoin
d'être assistés à son âge
bon oui mais un peu comme ça quand même
un usager lallaing
c'est pas non et déjà près d'el hri
cambon qui s'ignorent nous dit c'est pas
non est-ce que par amour ou seriez prête
à aller dans une boîte échangiste tous
les samedis soirs à
on
oui
[Applaudissements]
on y va ce soir c'est pas demain non non
un samedi sur deux à un samedi sur deux
tous les 15 jours parce que j'ai pensé à
l'amour et si j'allais vraiment qu
est-ce qui ça ça rapporte le mec fait ce
qu'il veut c'est la groupe et il sait
pas vraiment mais c'est en fait c'est
sans fin de fontanes c'est que là une
partie de cet homme je sait pas assez
mais non ça me plairait pas d'accord
ces quatre conscience là quand même hein
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
devenir son esclave sexuelle
sentir bon gars ben moi le premier
d'ailleurs
frédéric hallucinant cet homme qui rit à
10 ans qui arrive à imposer comme sauf
qu'hier des trucs de malade
les six nations avec moi il faut le
savoir ses démons est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à grossir de 10 kg si
le type aime bien les rues basses les
formes êtes d'accord qui construiront
vous êtes vous apparemment aussi de 10
kilos ça s'appelle tomber enceinte
notre invité ce soir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tabbou gbono plec kyle zut alors par
amour sophie thalmann seriez vous prête
à arrêter la télé
bah si on me demande s agirait que ce
qu'on n'est pas forcément amoureux de
moi ça ferait réfléchir paramo seriez
vous prête à quitter la france pour vous
exiler au paraguay
à noter peut être pourquoi pas ouais ça
pourquoi pas par amour auriez vous
recours à la chirurgie esthétique mais
encore gérer la même chose si on me
demande d'échangé par pas que ce soit
ouais c'est qu'on n'aime pas quand je
suis pas un mot ou est-ce que vous
accepteriez de vivre à trois avec sa
maîtresse surtout pas je ne partage pas
par amour est ce que vous seriez prête à
aller tous les samedis soir dans un club
échangiste encore mois bon ces fonds
pour la main bruno quand on aime
vraiment quelqu'un pense même agrément
quelqu'un on se laisse maquée par la
personne voit la femme ou homme voilà tu
fais pas un tatouage pour un mec à 6 à
11 ans et s'il a pu faire d'autre 9
avant que souvent nos fils de se faire
tatouer dont vacanciers un coeur brisé
parce que je le demande à tout mais sa
défense est pas là l on passe tout sur
la
même partie du corps elles le savent est
le bon je continuerai ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à devenir son esclave
sexuelle pas de mon fait marrant quand
même est-ce que par amour vous seriez
prête à embrasser cent fois ses
chaussettes sales sur la question
clotilde courau écouter ils vous
regardent souvent et il m'a souvent posé
cette question là et je lui dis non
ouais est-ce que par amour vous seriez
prête à prendre 20 kg s'il aime les rues
ben ouais ça
masi faudrait que je me ferai caca
est-ce que paramo vous seriez prête à ne
plus jamais faire l'amour parce qu'il
serait devenu impuissant dans un
accident de deltaplane
imaginez devienne un puissant il ya un
puissant en trouvera à prendre goût du
god we trust
ceci l'a quand même ouais je vais dire
oui je crois que ça sera dur n'oubliez
pas qu'il devienne un puissant quand
même bien est-ce que par un poco vous
seriez prête à ne jamais avoir d'enfant
car il veut rester votre seul enfant je
pense que je pourrais être pire de tous
les pires là est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à arrêter de fumer
est-ce que par un mot vous seriez prête
à fumer de l'aveu way we à vous l'aimez
vraiment alors fraîchement parce que
j'ai jamais mes cigarettes dans ma
bouche c'est parce que j ai bien bien
sophie d'allemagne ça fait quoi d'être
miss france non
on va faire l'interview par amour pour
la boucherie
[Musique]
dans la bouche pendant les dingle c'est
bien je peux bouger là maintenant par
amo est ce que vous seriez prêt à
arrêter de jouer de la guitare
c'est par amour pour vous et pour moi
oui mais par exemple pour mais alors si
ça lui plaît le plus c'est bien par amo
est ce que vous seriez prêt à cacher le
corps de quelqu'un que je viens de tuer
oui c'est un problème c'est rien est ce
que vous seriez prêt par amour arrêter
de fumer
dur dur là il faut aimer là on peut pas
fumer en plus on n'a plus droit de fumer
avant pourrait fumer du temps lunettes
noires ont fumé par amour ouais c'est
pas un jour sans lui avait prêté le sud
amour par amour
est-ce que vous accepteriez qu'elle est
un amant quand on aime les gens n'ont
envie qu'il soit heureux mais je suis
d'accord moi ça veut dire qu'ils aiment
plus non par amour est le sort est ce
que vous seriez prêt à accepter que j'ai
une maîtresse ouais c'est par amour on
est prêt à tout on est prêt à tout quand
on a tout par amour est ce que vous
seriez prêt à vivre avec ma maîtresse et
moi tous les froids est ce qu'elle est
s'il ya une chatte dans l'histoire et
vous qu'un ça c'était pas dans
l'interview châtelet est-ce que par
amour vous accepteriez que votre jules
et une maîtresse je crois pas non plus
mais pas alors mais si je sais quand
même les gens ont envie qu'il soit
heureux mais je fais tout pour qu'il
soit heureux pendant la dmn jeu c'est
tout pourri soit heureux oui mais j'ai
pas jusque là et vous mimi j'ai toujours
accepté qu'ils aient des femmes donc ça
fait beaucoup
parce que c'est ça ou rien mais c'est
bien comme ça vous avez pas tout le
temps sur le maroc n'est pas tout sur le
dos et mieux par amo est ce que vous
seriez prête aviv à trois avec le mec
est là mais tu n'as jamais et vous non
plus à n'ont rien à faire avec ces
gonzesses retrouver sans guitare thomas
si votre maîtresse moi si j'étais votre
amant mais peu importe
est ce que vous seriez prêt à aller tous
les samedis dans un club échangiste
bah ouais si je peux boire un coup ou
tant qu il si votre femme vous demande
si ma femme dans la cage il est tout de
suite
demandez moi c'est pas une idée à moi
l'une des cantines est ce que vous
seriez prêt alors je vais dire moi
puisque apparemment est quelque chose
qui se crée entre même ce soir par amour
est ce que vous seriez prêt à devenir
mon esclave sexuelle votre esclave
sexuelle aurait tout ce que je vous
demande de la section il fait tout cela
rend ma fille aussi dans le rang mais
non elle n'est pas très branché sexe non
et vous par exemple votre votre jules
vous dis voilà si tu m'aimes tu deviens
mon esclave sexuelle c'est votre
programme c'est l'esclavagé sexuel
je vais consulter les conseil national
interrégional des verts n'ont consulté
pas conseil national c'est pas ça prend
une semaine de négociations courant et
on n'y arrivera jamais par amour ou
est-ce que vous prendriez du viagra
il y en a dans les bois sont ici on est
remonté mois ci en plus j'en prends il
va t il va mourir
par amour
est ce que vous seriez prêt à vous
refaire faire le sexe comme je joue de
la guitare avec mon sexe zellik à partie
quand il sera avec 116 donc maintenant
nous passons à l'interview pas
les bouchons
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
génial
bien moyens michel larqué ce que par
amour vous pourriez refusé un rôle
oui oui oui est-ce que par amour vous
pourriez vous convertir à une autre
religion que la vôtre si je comprends
pourquoi c'est important pour lui oui
bien sûr michel vous vous auriez fait
prêt à changer de religion par un mot
lui nous chacun garde sa nuit jura ouais
ouais bah vous savez tout ça ça se
ressemble quand même pas pousser
peu importe le véhicule du monde arabe
le roi et le royaume moi je vais devenir
le pape de lattes ou bien est-ce que par
amour vous auriez recours à la chirurgie
esthétique
ah oui
si on regarde bien bizarre comme un
temple ici même pas comme ça la forme
était d'accord alors là ça devient plus
chaud est-ce que par amour vous
accepteriez qu'il est une maîtresse mais
c'est à dire que des manques avec moi
ouais
oui bon moi je c'est vrai que j'ai envie
qu'ils seraient donc vous soyez d'accord
mais faut pas trop que je le sache c'est
pas yaya et c'est difficile
ouais c'est pas lui a dit à la télé en
compte l'homme de solution avant une
solution est-ce que par amour vous
accepteriez de vivre à trois avec la
maîtresse est ce que par amour on
accepterait d'aller tous les soirs à 20
clubs d'échangés non plus est-ce que par
les accepterait de devenir son esclave
sexuelle quoi parce que non parce que
parce que parce que ça me voir parce
qu'il faut que ça me il faut que ça me
plaise
il faut lui faire plaisir il envie d'une
échelle sexuelle le pot attend qu'ils
voulaient mais oui mais oui mais je veux
dire le
je comprends pourquoi c'est toujours pas
mariée moi tu veux on te lâche jamais ça
veut dire beaucoup le sexe non hein
alors sept ans et je réfléchis ya donc
s'il veut unique cela une esclave
sexuelle c'est qu'il ya des trucs qui
vont peut-être peut-être je n'aime pas
non à huile à tunis est d'accord avec
arbres est-ce que par amour vous
accepteriez de prendre 20 kilos parce
qu'il adore les rubans dieu qui m'aime
comme juste voilà je ne veux plus changé
est-ce que par amour vous soyez prêt à
faire cet enfant en une fois en une fois
oui est-ce que par amour vous seriez
prête à cacher le corps de quelqu'un
qu'il vient de tuer non non non nos
peaux
il n'a pas fait exprès haye avait fait
exprès effectuer les dernières questions
le pire est ce que par amour vous seriez
prête à arrêter de fumer vous fasse
tache un jeu qui reprend le lendemain
des temples justement pour savoir ce que
vous êtes prête à faire par amour on va
faire une interview par amour on ne
bouge pas pendant les ting
non
bon assez vite concentre toi on cherche
un jules
est ce que vous êtes prête à sacrifier
votre carrière
par amour non bah ouais ah non mais ça
j'ai toujours été très flatteur vous
dites pour les jours mais non mais quand
on quand on quand on aime on respecte ce
que l'autre fait bien sûr mais mon
métier c'est celui qui m'a fait vivre et
qui m'a sortie de pas mal de choses que
je lâcherai pas non est-ce que paramo
vous vous convertir à l'islam
c'est encore non parce que je crois que
tout ce qui est religieux et qui empêche
l'épanouissement de l'amour etc me fait
plus ou moins peur parce que je trouve
que c'est dans l'extrême
je sais pas de jugement à porter là
dessus mais moi je pense que je ferai
pas
vous n'êtes pas croyante parce que ça le
problème peut-être mais peut-être du mal
à croire quand j'en plus je vois tout ce
qui se passe dans le monde à cause des
religions etc
moi j'ai eu un vrai problème et invitant
à cause des religions sacoche des
extrémistes oui les extrémistes je suis
d'accord avec vous mais moi en tout cas
la base est là et c'est vrai que depuis
depuis dé décider des siècles c'est
comme ça non moi je crois en quelque
chose je crois au destin je crois en une
force quand une volonté je crois en
plein de choses on est tous maîtres de
nos vies et de nos destins et et puis
voilà après chaque lancé par amour oui
prendriez 20 kilos si le mec qui aime
les os
wahou non non non non rien du tout à
vous droguez par amour non à héberger
ses parents par amour qui prendrait
barrichello qui se désole parce que mon
papa maman je peux donner tous mes deux
mois de ce que je suis de ce que je te
connais un homme mais va arrêter de
fumer par exemple par amour [ __ ] c'est
dur ça voilà par amour vous accepteriez
qu'il est une maîtresse m'a servi un peu
la question de la fidélité tout à
l'heure vous voulez mais tellement voulu
qu'il soit heureux
vous êtes d'accord pour qu'il ait une
maîtresse le pauvre christ en maïs en
agissant à faire souffrir
super héros de le voir à l'extérieur
logique quand même un livre à 3 par aman
j'ai pas partageuse non ouais poser des
problèmes je comprends ça me parait ça
quand même comme dans l'amour est ce que
vous iriez dans un club échangiste ça
oui ça non
peut-être pour voir mais je sais pas
mais je comprends que vous êtes toujours
si vous n'êtes pas d'accord on antique
voulais pas non je voudrais pas parce
que je serai pas ça ça parait tout
concentré pas je serai pas à l'aise de
là dedans moi au bout d'un moment
non sincèrement je pense pas que je
serais à l'aise au début mais je vous en
prie je vous n'êtes jamais allé jamais
une arme est tout à fait voilà c'est ça
que vous dites ça mais sûrement
peut-être mais en attendant je sais tu
peux y aurait pas la démarche de le
faire je crois que je serais choqué
c'est mon mec me demandait ça mais c'est
pas moi qui vous le demande
célibataire après on est pas mariés
c'est toujours non je suis pas marié
voilà vous êtes toujours quelque part is
money pour le mariage
exactement donc on va savoir ce que vous
êtes prêts à faire par amour comme ça
toutes les filles pourront juger si vous
êtes un bon mari on va faire une
interview pas amour légal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que par amour vous arrêteriez de
faire votre métier
non parce que j'ai de la personnalité
arrête tes conneries ou amanda par amour
je fais n'importe quoi l'amour passe
avant tout apparemment je renonce à ma
mon métier je me fait refaire la ouais
je me teins envers ça c'est si tu sors
avec elle tu vas par amour titeuf est ce
que vous arrêteriez de vous droguez je
sais déjà fait en fait ouais j'ai déjà
fais là j'ai arrêté j'ai dit plus que
plus qu'à la noël en famille
sinon le reste de l'année c'est fini a
caché le corps de la personne qu'elle
vient de tuer au
non la noix je la dénonce d'abord j'ai
des noms lui qu'est ce tu fais tapis
moquette est ce que par amour vous
accepteriez qu'elle a un amant
si c'est un bon copain huawei
quelle horreur juste posé ces questions
avoue bernard parce que moi je trouve
que quand les corps n'ont plus rien à se
dire je suis pas la séparation des corps
des liens
facilement prendre de temps en temps si
le prêtre est ce que par amour titov
vous seriez prêt à fréquenter des clubs
échangistes jeu c'est plutôt démodé je
trouve un les plus que les vieux mec de
la télé
c'est fini thierry oui on m'a passé un
petit billet la ccsn personnes
il a marqué passe de l'autre côté c'est
la guerre des étoiles
c'est quand même c'est pour équilibrer
jacques guèye gaye on va faire une
interview par amour c'est normal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce bâtiment
[Musique]
david vous êtes des affiches installées
du caractère cette petite avira loin
bien alors par amour est ce que vous
pourriez arrêté de chanter oui oui
vraiment si vous demander d'arrêter de
chanter volunteer qu'il ne demanderait
pas mais si je devais faire une famille
que ça ça me sam ce serait contre contre
ça oui j'arrêterai ah d'accord
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
vous exiler en nouvelle zélande
non parce que je vais habiter en israël
est lui aussi dans un monde ça fait des
années qu'ils espéraient sera fini pour
tourner là bas
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
vous faire refaire les seins
je ne connais pas les faits mais si vous
lisez je veux que tes dessins de talia
par exemple ou de bons très pauvre et
qu'ils aiment sa fin pour moi mais bon
non non non
moi ce que je fais c'est pour lui parce
qu'il regarde l'émission je suis sûr et
je veux savoir
vous feriez pour lui par exemple la
fameuse question clotilde courau est ce
que par amour vous seriez prête à
embrasser cent fois ses chaussettes
sales
oui la chance les gars on a pas
d'hésitation
oui france et s'y étant affaibli ne
brille que c'est d'accord aussi
oui d'ailleurs est-ce que par amour vous
seriez prête à prendre 20 kilos parce
qu'il aime les rues basses est-ce que je
n'aimerais pas mois après je laime
rappel ça va tu peux rien c'est énorme
mais non maintenant sativa s'attira bien
parce qu'à dix heures tu as très beau
format de visages minutes
celle ci compte en 2d au q3
c'est vrai
génial
c'est lamentable est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à cacher le corps de
quelqu'un qui vient de tuer elle
mangeait non ménagers non mais le cachet
très aimé et gala du coup je pense que
là bas ils vont aux [ __ ] c'est
incroyable
[Applaudissements]
alors est-ce que par amour vous
accepteriez qu'il est une maîtresse
non vous l'aimez pas alors avec comme la
femme d'accord qu'elle vient à manches
cela la rendait heureuse pas du tout
donc par amour vous soyez pas prêtes à
vivre à trois avec la maîtresse par
exemple pourtant dans un kibboutz a
montré qu il ya de la place
ouais c'est vrai mais non non voilà les
clubs échangistes pas mon truc à moi
avec la maîtresse
non on arrive attention on arrive à la
question de la fiche 69 et les messieurs
et là je me méfie parce que c'est vous
qui me posait une question puis voyant
comment vous êtes je suis prêt à tout
d'abord lancé
est-ce que vous avez des rêves vous avez
pas encore accompli et qu elle sentie
comme rêve oui j'aimerais bien produire
un film de long métrage
voilà pas de réaliser ce que l'on serait
sûrement pas capable mais le produire
oui ça me plairait de faire du long
métrage
voilà c'est un peu dans le milieu des
boîtes échanges et là c'est un truc
normalement vous devriez être d'accord
je sais pas mais bon est-ce que par
amour ou seriez prête à devenir son
esclave sexuelle
oui est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à arrêter de fumer a
commencé à fumer non donc bon oui oui je
sais pas bon pour la voix ouais si en
plus je dois arrêter de chanter et
commencent à fumer en 20 kg oui où les
allemands voulaient me dit lui dans
votre cas la caméra regarder
en angleterre vous êtes comme un tout le
royal que c'est les médias qui font
monter la sauce vous l'aimé beaucoup
david beckham est très amoureuse de lui
c'est vrai que vous l'avez ses shorts sa
femme
comment pourrait elle est mariée
pourquoi et marie-mai tu comprends bah
oui j'ai tout ça très beau de laver les
scream de son mari mme bah ouais voilà
c'est dit est-ce que vous la verriez by
sleep de l'autre mary n'ont rien n'est
pas parce que jamais mariés mais si on
me mettra pas de slip
je connais un qui me concerne avec
monsieur le boeuf mais oui mais thierry
vous êtes vous êtes vous ne mettez pas
de slip donc elle peut vivre
dites moi à victoria il ya une question
qui est très célèbre dans cette émission
c est ce que par amour vous embrasse
seriez sans fois les chaussettes sales
de votre amoureux c'est la question
clotilde courau que les habitués des
missions connaissent bien et février les
médecins voulaient que je le fasse oui
oh la la
c'est la plus des comme ça j'étais
tatoué jeu m'a fait la paix pour lui
prouver que je l'aimais donc savez les
chaussettes sales c'est pas trop dur ça
va me faire tatouer en effet les
chaussettes à ma femme
j'irais pas jusqu'a et si ma femme très
jolies pièces en mouvement des pieds je
pense pas que bon bah oui c'est ça
l'amour fringues aph mais je crois qu'il
faut je crois qu'il fallait au bout de
l'histoire
on va faire une interview par amour
important meeting âge
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
très bien est-ce que par amour vous
seriez prête à arrêter de chanter ah oui
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
vous convertir à l'islam
oh non non non non est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à vous faire refaire
le visage par un chirurgien
il voulait lui
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
prendre 20 kg oui s'il fallait est-ce
que par amour enfin c'est terrible vous
seriez prête à vous déguiser en elton
john c'est dur je sais c'est dur mais
bon quand on aime quelqu'un en même
temps tout ce qu'il faudra que je fasse
je le ferais là est-ce que par amour
si ça le rendait heureux vous seriez
prête à accepter qu'il ait une maîtresse
non non vous l'aimez pas vraiment alors
ça veut dire que je peux pas partager
quelqu'un que j'aime quand on aime que
l'amour c'est quelque chose de
réciproque s'est déclenchée mais quel
point elle en fait on s'attend à du
respect de l'amour et s'il avait une
maîtresse ça voudrait dire qu'ils ne me
respectent pas
[Musique]
ça va est-ce que par amour vous seriez
prête à devenir son esclave sexuelle
would you be comme sex live for love tu
vois et vous mais peut-être il est
lui-même mon esclave c'est ça l'histoire
et pas franck moi je suis l'esclave
sexuelle de ma femme quand elle veut
quand vous venez ici pour la première
fois vous aviez dit à patrick bruel
qu'il était un petit peu pour vous le
portrait de l'homme idéal et depuis me
parle de vous ils se sont revus
ah bon je sais tout s'est jamais rue
il s'est vanté c'est pas vrai mais il ya
tout le monde quitte à pécho 1
bâillements sa mythomanie donc tu es
gentil ce soir ya déjà un avantage ça
suffit alors vous dites le mieux avec
les mecs ça serait un bail de deux ans
renouvelable c'est pas mal dans les
filles les mecs ont peur de vous draguez
nant je suis sûr moi je vous est grande
vous mesurez 1 m 77 non c'est vrai que
j'ai pas tellement de poitrine mais bon
ça fait rien mais les mecs ont peur de
vous draguez non c'est vrai qu'ils ont
peur mais c'est que je suis un peu en
froid avec un prix d'entretien un garçon
qui aime passer chez nous qui a peut
être qu'elle fait pas donc elle était
sûrement
bien le problème laurent c'est quoi
c'est qu'elle a un oeil tatoué dans le
dos quand vous avez j'avoue c'est
patrick qui me l'a dit
qu'est-ce qui me l'a dit je le sais
c'est toujours bien sûr personne ne me
l'a dit je sais tout moi vous savez que
cette hausse est presque
[Applaudissements]
il ya toujours plus bas fils derrière
moi qu'en fin d'année
noémie lenoir si vous ne répondez pas
une question c'est yvan attal qui répond
c'est le principe du joker merci génial
moi je suis pas non plus est-ce que par
amour
vous seriez prête à vous convertir à
l'islam je passe
ben oui ça va être dur on va surtout par
an l'assuré le tout de suite tu vas pas
de convertir à l'islam bien dois me le
noir est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à vous faire refaire
les seins faire faire
et les hommes des enfants ça existe un
non non non est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à vous mettre au troc
dur
ah non si vous voulez mais pas vraiment
alors je pense pas qu'il pourrait me
dire je l'accepterai jamais ça à la
maison d'accord à la maison est ce que
est ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
faire cinq enfants
oui en même temps par une famille de
foot
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
prendre 17 kg oui pourquoi pas la
question clotilde courau que les
habitués de cette émission connaissent
bien est ce que par amour vous seriez
prête à embrasser cent fois les
chaussettes sales de votre amoureux
alors c'est comme les jeux aux etats
unis quand ils doivent les chiens et non
aux états unis à des émissions où il
gagne environ dix mille francs et
doivent aller chez des rambardes comme
dans le train je vais manger des
excréments des jeux ça je comprends que
cela dit c'est bon marché mac do
mike golding là qui m'a prêté jean
pierre coffe 1 2s qu'apparemment vous
accepteriez qu'il est une maîtresse non
pas si vous l'aimez vous faisiez alors
maintenant je change
j'oublie un fidélité si ça le rend
heureux d'avoir une maîtresse et main
qu'il est une maîtresse avec quelqu'un
d'autre mais pas moi en tout cas qu'il
est une maîtresse avec sa femme voilà en
tout cas d'accord d'accord donc vous
seriez pas d'accord pour vivre à trois
avec la maîtresse c'est même pas la
peine que je vous pose des questions
n'ont ni à 4 c'est la question est-ce
que par amour
vous seriez prête à devenir son esclave
sexuelle
c'était attendu
mais mu
mais
mais milliards
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
mais oui tu serais tu prêt de karamoja
devenir son esclave sexuelle
danic tâche
[Applaudissements]
en même temps si elles travaillent sur
cette émission c'est un petit peu obligé
alors vous attirer alors il en est par
amour vous seriez prêt à devenir son
esclave sexuelle sans problème sans
problème problème c'est un homme
ouais à bord pour une femme c'est plus
dur d'être esclave sexuel quand même
c'est pas pareil c'est sympa et staff
sexuelle mais il ya un truc qui n'a pas
envie de faire à ses vrais plein
le cauchemar pour leur single
[Musique]
est-ce que par amour pour lui vous
seriez prête à vous déguiser en est je
regardais déjà
est-ce que par amour pour lui vous
seriez prête à arrêter de chanter
non non est ce que vous seriez prêtre
par amour à vous convertir à l'islam et
à passer votre vie voit les noms la
voulez mais pas tant que ça finalement
en fait non est ce que vous seriez
prêtre par amour à vous faire refaire
les seins
non et parmi vous seriez prête à prendre
17 kg tu vous le demandait nom et par
gourmandise
bien sûr ça oui vous seriez prête paramo
a caché le corps de quelqu'un qui vient
de tuer non non est-ce que par amour
vous accepteriez qu'il est une maîtresse
non vous soyez pas d'accord pour vivre à
trois avec la maîtresse lendemain a dit
aïe aïe aïe
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
faire des partouzes
non allez y c'est la dernière question
c'est la pire kelly vous êtes prête
est ce que vous seriez prêtre par amour
à devenir son esclave sexuelle alors bah
oui oh
[Applaudissements]
c'est motivé les motiver mes p'tits gars
mais qu'est ce qui vous donne à l'île
maurice pour que vous revenez dans cet
état là il me promettent de patin de
photos et c est un contrat
[Applaudissements]
je voyage avec une moche on me fout la
boucle est ce que par amour
vous accepteriez de vous déguiser en
étonne jaune oui est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à reprendre les dix
kilos que vous avez perdu
oui est-ce que par amour vous seriez
prête à tourner dans un film
pornographique ont créé ou d'autres vous
l'aimez vraiment est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à arrêter de fumer
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
cacher le corps de quelqu'un qu'il vient
de tuer parce que par un mot vous seriez
prête à devenir scientologues
c'est quelqu'un c'est pas bien philippe
se convertit à la scientologie tom
cruise attention comme tom cruise
consommateurs comme travolta dans son
principal voulait épouser pas bien joué
ils gardent bien est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à vous installer à
limoges oui mais tes filets
tu sors messieurs voici voici la
question non pas du tout voici la
question de clotilde courau oui voilà
mon vous seriez prête à embrasser cent
fois des chaussettes sales comme tout il
de gros et pas vraiment vous seriez
prête à faire six enfants
oui est-ce que par amour vous
accepteriez qu'il y ait une maîtresse si
vous l'aimez
calme-toi thierry commencé à prêcher
pour sa paroisse saint préféré pas oui
mais mais par amour et je vire vire la
maison oh la la il est où ce philippe
qu'on voit qu'on voit que ce à quoi il
ressemble
catherine n'est pas fini on va voir tout
de suite si c'est la meilleure
productrice de paris catherine barma
philippe doit venir se montrer parce que
quand une fille est presque mort
mais
filippi j'en attends moi une fille qui
fait ça
elle sera une petite navette walhain
fini parce que là est branché sur
d'armand havane ali si tu veut la
récupérer c'est maintenant quand tu te
casses fx alors qu'evan baissier
série
ce masque par amour tu accepterais
qu'elle a un amant
j'ai aussi des nas ou par peur de vous
décevoir en fait j'ai vu en loge la
façon dont elle parlait de moi je mets
cénacois l'a même dit elle même dit
qu'elle était prête à ce que tu es une
maîtresse mais ça je suis pas sûr que ce
soit pas que pour la télé quand on est
d'accord
en tous les cas dont je vous présente
les dames messieurs vie je longe
quelques médias on l'applaudît
bravo dont tu vas rester jusqu'à la fin
puisque là là si tu veux ya deux trois
questions
je préfère que tu sois là philippe j'te
jure
gérard darmon
merci mais bon il ya des moments où il
faut bon est-ce que je peux juste donner
une anecdote syrie très très drôle
les parents de gérard cavaillé à savent
ni sur an juste en face de chez mes
parents c'est bien tu sais ça parce que
nous sommes à tes potes
las alors vous êtes connu petit nom
alors est-ce que par amour vous êtes
prête à vivre à trois avec la maîtresse
de philippe
et maintenant m messieurs là c'est une
question importante parce que philippe
ce que je veux dire à berne afin qu'elle
est venue au texte est fan de marie par
les pattes c'est grâce à moi de les
dissuader certaines salles bien finir
mais là aujourd'hui je pense pas que je
vais dissuader vanessa demouy d'aller
plus loin
bien alors est-ce que par amour vanessa
demouy vous êtes prête à devenir son
esclave sexuelle
ah ouais puisqu'on est dans une période
où on est et où vous avez déjà couché en
raison de la sécheuse paramount a déjà
couché avec une fille non on a dit qu'on
n'en parlait pas
à long terme vous êtes amoureuse nous en
sommes très heureux et on va voir tout
ce que vous seriez prête à faire par
amour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
arrêter le cinéma
attention non parce que c'est pas
quelque chose qui ne demanderaient pas
bon non il est bien quand tu es bien ce
mec là bien est-ce que par amour vous
seriez prête à retourner vivre à tahiti
aujourd'hui non mais semaine peut-être
je veux
j'aimerais être être grand-mère à tahiti
enfin de sumo grand mère grand mérite
est est ce que par amour vous seriez
prête à cacher quelqu'un qu'il vient de
tuer vous êtes ardisson il est
c'est carrément à bissau c'est du foot
je vais déjà je fais des jeux de mots et
à l'homme et 10 dont celle où il s'est
laissé trois mois tu a progressé mais
bourillon à mais j'ai beaucoup bouquiner
non arrête donc est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à cacher quelqu'un
qu'il vient de tuer d'un coup de couteau
dans le ventre
nanti d'un nouvel apport il dit je les
buts et chérie et vous dites et où il
est dans le coffre mais tu dis mais
qu'est ce qu'on va faire
il faut que tu m'aides à le cacher fait
quoi là allez on a calmé dans le coffre
il dit non bon dans le moteur alors je
me coule je coule le cadavre à vous
mettez les pieds du cadavre dans du
béton et vous jetez le cadart par un
pont dans la seine d'accord d'accord je
peux prendre le même truc que vous ouais
est ce que c'est un très beau
or font de rosé est ce que par amour
vous seriez prête
mareva galanter à vous mettre à la
drogue bat pour eux c'est faire la
charité qui sous le piton par canal+
commercial est bien scellé nouveau
canard c'est vivendi ya plus de domicile
et dingo canada corp la drogue
imaginez un soir il arrive il vous dit
ça y est moi je me suis accroché à
l'héroïne c'est super essaye montre
tombera feriez quoi je vous sais pas ce
que vous dites mais c'est pas un
horrible ça peut arriver je l' ai vu ça
déjà c'est que des scènes et j'ai vu ses
baies sont pas des questions leur état
d'esprit que j'avance
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
prendre 17 kg j'en ai pris dix ans
j'étais miss france dont nous 17 à fait
d'accord et je vois pas pourquoi wade
bassila mais rubens ou les botero peux
vous dire à prendre 17 kg pour faire
plaisir je crois qu'après tout ça si tu
me demandes et tout ça je serais plus je
serai prête je l'entends je voudrais pas
que cette annonce est bien sûr question
tautil de kuro d'irma la douce
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
embrasser cent fois ses chaussettes
sales mareva voulez mais un peu quand
même
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
vous faire refaire le nez
pourquoi il est pas bon cécile b
attendez c'est pas la question
oui mais justement la nuit vous
willems a des gros noms je ne veux même
pas imaginer ce que je pourrais devenir
après tout ça aussi c'est tout ça pour
sept kilos de grossesse oui puisque pour
la drogue et tu sais
moi
moi non mais c'est un test c'est pour
voir s'ils s'aiment
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
accepter quelque petit tout petit pull
infidélité beau juste le bout des
possibilités
alors si on est complice pourquoi pas à
intéressant je trouve ça dégueulasse
est-ce que par amour vous accepteriez
qu'il est maîtresse non je voulais même
pas hors des questions petit salon
heureux d'avoir une maîtresse
il peut pas être heureux d'avoir une
maîtresse il arrête moi c'est pas
possible donc vous vivez pas à trois
avec la maîtresse
non vous refuseriez d'année tous les
droits dans des clubs échangistes c'est
pas la peine que je me les pose cette
question
moi je n'ai qu'une affaire des questions
pour vous et d'y répondre voilà alors
tant pis est-ce que par amour vous
seriez prête à devenir son esclave
sexuelle
ah et bien mesdames messieurs pierre
castillon prouve dans ce livre qu'elle
sait aimer nous allons donc faire une
interview par amour
le mouvement va fils ne va pas bien na
est ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
arrêter d'écrire arrêté de publier oui
arrêtez d'écrire à ces gosses c'est beau
est-ce que par amour ou seriez prête à
ne pas faire d'enfant
oui on va faire six enfants aussi est-ce
que par amour vous seriez prête à cacher
quelqu'un qu'il vient de tuer
oui way le tuer avec lui même le lait il
a tourné
l'escp amour c
je la mets dans mon spectacle je fait un
carton au zénith de montpellier
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
vous mettre à la drogue n'ont pas si
vous l'aimez pas vraiment à la noce et
qui se droguent ou pas elle drague pas
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
prendre 17 kg non allez perdre mais pas
les perdre
bats toi qu'est-ce qui va vous restez
est clair est-ce que par amour vous
seriez prête à accepter quelques
infidélités
non ohlala
non est-ce que paramore là vous êtes
compliqué quand même parce que bon
est-ce qu apparemment vous seriez prête
à accepter qu'il ait une maîtresse non
est-ce que par amour c'est la question
clotilde courau vous seriez prête en
brasse et 100 fois la mise et
chaussettes sales
oui chaque chose et chaque show 700 fois
à est-ce que par amour est question
est-ce que sans la boîte échangiste
loisy presse est-ce que par un mot vous
seriez prête à vivre à trois avec sa
maîtresse et viril il ya maintenant ça
rejoint la seule chose à faire si on lui
en fait c'est tuer et léché les
chaussettes
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
aller a vécu dans un club et un bras
[Applaudissements]
cinéma
alors j'aime que les hommes qui
supportent qui ne supporte même pas
l'idée de me partager en fait la faute à
papa à melilla tapotage savard et d'y
aller vers soignies la totale est-ce que
par amour ou seriez prête à devenir son
espoir aux tapis déjà d'accord là est-ce
que par amour vous seriez prête
merci d'être avec nous ce soir vous dans
la vie vous êtes vous êtes aimés c'est
pas une illusion c'est pas de
l'érotomanie témoin mais souvent on vous
adore non mais les gens que j'aime même
ouais c'est un succès fou moi je n'en
sais rien du tout ni l'agent jay un
tract aura seulement toutes mes copines
me disent dans la merde pas du tout
c'était comme tous mes disques des
bâches mambo qu'elle aimerait bien être
avec vous que vous laissez d'user
beaucoup qu'est ce qu'elle dit
[Musique]
oh
est-ce qu'elle n'est pas jalouse c'est
non ah non non c'est une femme
formidable
alors c'est pas d'aller à l'ombre aux
autres samuel vous avez déclaré je sais
que c'est le début de notre carrière
mais j'ai du mal à résister à une fille
qui me demande quelque chose en faisant
les yeux doux
voilà c'est fini c'est manifestement
serge êtes vraiment fidèle ouais alors
que vous êtes devenu star êtes bien
profiter de votre succès non moi je dis
vous avez bien profité non les restos
cher les boîtes de nuit bon je vis du
temps à rattraper
on a toujours envie de profiter des
choses femis est donc les chats tous à
l'homme il a dit le bihan une formidable
dans certains jeux pour réussir
moi j'ai réussi pour coucher c'est pas
qu'on voit là avant que moi je montais
pas un rêve c'est vrai on va voir ce que
vous seriez prêt ou pas à faire par
amour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
samuel le bihan est ce que nous ont fait
peur en chaîne
mieux alors samuel le bihan est ce que
par amour vous seriez prêt à mettre une
perruque blonde
ouais ouais ouais apparemment bien sûr
dernier la demande vous la mettez y en a
déjà demandé d'être une perruche la vie
mais est ce que est ce que par amour
vous seriez prêt à arrêter le cinéma du
jour au lendemain
ah ouais il ya un caméscope est ce que
par amour ou seriez prêt à vous
convertir à une autre religion
la finance vous seriez prêt à cacher
quelqu'un qu'elle vient de tuer ont même
tué quelqu'un qui vient de cacher
[Applaudissements]
et là potage tapenade
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prêt à
vous remettre à la drogue
bien sûr la potage
ça fait deux heures est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prêt en brasse et 100 fois
les chaussettes sales de daniela c'est
la question peut-il le court aux
ouvriers alors on a beaucoup parlé n'est
pas d'accord donc non est-ce que par
amour vous seriez prêt à vous faire
refaire le nez
ah ouais en plus grands salons de bien
rentrer dans un certain nombre de
questions auxquelles on avait du mal à
répondre
huawei est ce que par amour ou seriez
prêts à accepter quelques infidélités
bien sûr
parce que tu m'as pas demandé si c'était
avec un homme ou une femme dont j'ai mis
la question et je n'en dirai pas plus
est-ce que par amour ou seriez prêt à
accepter que daniela est un amant prince
christian très chiant parce qu' il
serait bachelot moins drôle vraiment oui
faut c est ce que est ce que vous seriez
prêt par amour à aller dans un club
échangiste avec des timbres des diggers
panini rentrée
je les ai tout dit sans qu'avec voir joe
hart ici pour participer peut-être déjà
fait non content parce que c'est glauque
c'est du cul triste ouais les portes et
jamais de mieux une soirée carlos est ce
que par amour
vous seriez prêt à devenir l'esclave
sexuelle de daniela je suis déjà à son
ex
est ce que voit on
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prêt à
changer de sexe maintenant un petit 13
il changé vous seriez le magma choisi
non pas du tout c'est marrant ça aura
quand même faire une interview par aman
en revanche pendant ledit galles en
bouche par le nombre de bouchons
[Musique]
c'est pourquoi je sais que moi je alors
allons-y interview par amour
est-ce que par amour ou seriez prête à
vous déguiser en elton john
ah oui ah oui ah oui c'est certain la
chance nous prend beaucoup sur toi
est-ce que par amour vous serez presse
qui se déguise en elton john et on avait
des conflits des pas son nom
à est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête
à arrêter de faire du cinéma
j'ai déjà quitté quelqu'un parce qu'il
m'a empêché de faire du cinéma
ouh là là là et c'était avant de
commencer et bah je pense que j'ai bien
fait d'accord donc je pense qu'on jette
j'aurais du mal
restez avec quelqu'un qui m'empêche de
faire ce qui m'épanouit donc d'accord
est-ce que parent m'ouvre seriez prête
elle habite et s'étend à londres et à
faire la cuisine c'est un à londres
c'est sûr et certain j'adore cette ville
on va accueillir et faire la cuisine je
me débrouillerai pour pas le faire tous
les soins tels que par amour vous soyez
prêtes à vous convertir à une autre
religion
j'ai failli aussi à quelle religion des
films zizou ah bon oui est vraiment
pendant deux ans je disais que pour ça
j'étais plus juive que certains jeudis
suivants
donc oui boulimie est révolue qui arrête
le cinéma et non il n'a pas fallu que
j'arrête il n'a même pas voulu que je
commence
ouais est-ce que par amour vous seriez
prête à ne pas faire d'enfant
si je perds en adopter un
non vraiment pas apparemment paramore
amour apparemment oui
pas un mot est-ce que par amour vous
seriez prête à cacher quelqu'un qu'il
vient de tuer oui mais jean galerie
sérieux après pas vraiment c'est pas
bien ce que tu as fais bien attention
c'est une moquette est ce que vous
seriez prête à prendre 17 kg oui oui
mais les hommes vous est terrible parce
que vous dites pas moisi prend 17 petits
d'eau puis après vous qui parce que vous
êtes une grosse faute sur ben oui oui
mais question clotilde courau est ce que
par amour
soyez prête à embrasser cent fois oui je
sais je connais cette question posée la
question chez cette salle wissang fois
par amour vous non gars qui me demande
ça
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
accepter quelques petites infidélités
tigresse pour ça dans mon garçon amine
purgé dix chaussettes à ça je suis sûr
êtes d'accord
est-ce que par un mot vous soyez prête à
devenir son esclave sexuelle
je vois pas très bien ce que ça veut
dire mais pourquoi pas sdf sexuelles
faites tout ce qui vous dit oui j'ai
confiance en lui je sais que ça peut pas
aller trop un trop loin il ira pas jusqu
à me tuer donc ça ira dommage quand même
9 h de quoi qu'il arrive pas trop long
sur les wii d'elle oui c'est miley est
sûre il avec ma mère j'entends des
excuses de merde
alors michèle torr l'amour a toujours
tenu une grande place dans votre vie
dans vos chansons vous êtes la cliente
idéale pour une interview
par amour
[Applaudissements]
oui est-ce que pas mon vous seriez prête
à tout arrêter de chanter par amour du
public
on est déjà lui même pas s'ils me disent
ah ben si on me demande ça je ne le
donnent en est ce que par amour vous
seriez prête à prendre 17 kilos mais je
crois que c'est parce que par est-ce que
par amour oui j'y prête à vous mettre à
la drogue tue pétard ça fait pas trop
mal
est ce que tu as à rebours soyez pas tu
as changé de chemisiers est ce que est
ce que par amour question peut-il de
courant vous seriez prête à embrasser
cent fois ses chaussettes sales par
amour oui un peu con la drogue le tabac
est ce que par amour ou seriez prête à
accepter quelques petites infidélités
par amour ouais ben tiens pas vraiment
évident de suivre ça drôle pour qui
c'est qui dit ça c'est vous les hommes
qui disent oui c'est le rendre bah oui
sûrement
lipow ça peut arriver
ouais vous accepterez j'aurais du mal à
accepter
d'accord c'est arrivé ça peut arriver
voilà c'est arrivé
est-ce que par amour vous accepteriez
c'est plus grave qu'il ait une maîtresse
non non non non non non non non non même
si ça me renvoie comme ça tu en entends
une erreur oui donc je vous demande pas
si par amour ou seriez prête à vivre à
trois avec la maîtresse
non non j'aurais beaucoup de mal
d'accord aurait des morts aller tous les
trois dans un club échangiste harris et
michel ettorre pas teddy emmène moi
danser ce soir ce qui rajoute dans un
club échangiste
il suffit d'écouter les disques séparant
de l'été c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que par amour je serai prête à
devenir sa super esclaves sexuelles les
i mean a thing
oui oui si je sens que ça ne devait pas
en outre la bras n'ont jamais vu à part
isabelle alonso est ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à changer de sexe si
vous voulez mais il vous aime et vous
dit si tu m'as tu n'aimes voilà je
t'aime et si tu m'aimes vraiment devient
un homme pour moi dans une autre vie
alors pas bon alors michel mercier vous
avez fait beaucoup de choses par amour
vous est même resté une fois 22 jours
sans manger par amour c'est vrai et
alors interview par amour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que parmi vous seriez prête à
vous déguiser en elton john battelle
plaisir apparemment on papa est-ce que
par amour vous seriez prête à cacher
quelqu'un qu'il vient de tuer par amour
possible
est-ce que par amour vous soyez prêtes à
vous mettre à la drogue
thiam a pas un bon vous l'aimez pas
vraiment alors quand on aime
non il ya des choses qui est un bon
est-ce que par un faux vous soyez prêtes
à prendre 17 kg
sûrement pas j'essaye de les perdre
alors là c'est bien parce que rosa par
amour vous seriez prête à embrasser cent
fois ses chaussettes sales par amour
bon ok d'accord seul ok bah amour à ses
chaussettes son propre camp c'est mieux
salle c'est bien kassav jeudi le cours
on nous a pris six que c'était des
chaussettes sales est l'asacar ok ok
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
accepter quelques petites infidélités
jamais jamais non je les ai acceptées
c'était trop tard donc pas vous
accepteriez pas qu'il est une maîtresse
après je suis là angélique jeter quand
il en avait je ne le savais pas comment
un si c'était terminé
apparemment vous soyez pas prêtes à
vivre à trois avec la mettra jamais
est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à fréquenter des clubs
échangistes aussi angélique au kit qu'à
ceux du col sont belles est-ce que par
amour vous seriez prête à devenir son
esclave sexuelle ça oui
c'est mon jeu est-ce que par amour vous
seriez prête à vendre votre corps pour
lui mais c'était touche l'argent pour
une fois
avant d'accepter de coucher avec vous on
m'a d'abord savoir ce que vous seriez
prête à faire par amour
[Applaudissements]
attention irène est ce que par amour
vous soyez prêtes à vous déguiser en
elton john rihana bien que oui oui vous
êtes prête à vous déguiser mais j'aime
bien c'est un coup l'un est ce que vous
seriez prête irène par amour à vous
droguez par amour situations extrêmes
vraiment vraiment vraiment extrême oui
en cas qu'est oui non est ce que vous
seriez prêt à tirer une par amour à
prendre 17 kg oui en cas non
kewell oui à la ça nous aide à choisir
nous aussi ouais c'est bien pour nous
c'est tournez manège vraiment là est-ce
que par amour
est-ce que par amour irène ne seriez
prête à aller vivre à limoges 5e pluton
tu vas adorer
oui vous vous souvenez oui oui oui oui
oui
limoges vous seriez ben oui oui je serai
pas les moyens bien parce que par amour
irène vous seriez prête à cacher
quelqu'un qu'il vient de tuer alors il
faut que je réfléchisse ouhlala bah on
n'a pas le temps
oui d'accord
oui oui oui par amour oui oui si je
laime c'est que oui en cas de oui
non non est-ce que par un mauvais rennes
vous seriez prête à embrasser cent fois
ses chaussettes sales
oui nous allons les élus verts moi j'ai
un faible pour ivan début des pieds
patrick vaz et moi est-ce que par amour
en car vous seriez printemps brasse et
100 fois ses chaussettes sales question
clotilde courau la main qui demande à
garder mangue ça ne fait pas l'amour
dégage tout de suite
la la la
là ça sent pas beaucoup mais le mont
houy
mais je t'aime pas
qu'est-ce que par amour vous seriez
prête
grand brun c'est cent fois ses
chaussettes sales alors cent fois oui
parce que je suis j'ai la tunisie est
alors c'est pas trop bien est ce que par
amour vous accepteriez irène quelques
petites infidélités à son nom mais avec
moi israël et gaza l'appelation coup c
est ce que nous en cas vous accepteriez
quelques petites bio fidélité moi j'aime
dans l'eau qu'est ce que j'ai les soirs
je suis jamais une fille belle je pense
pas que jamais alors que ouais et baba
écoutez si moi je pense que enfin si
c'est une seule fois je peux pardonner
tout cas pour que c'est vraiment un mais
deux fois ça casse à accueillir deux
fois non monsieur ridicule deux fois
deux fois et quand on sait jamais si on
goûte à prix attention c'est beaucoup
plus grave
maintenant ils renaissent que par un mot
vous accepteriez de vivre à 3
non non non si c'est une chienne louis
saint chéron
un grand passé
alors ok merci quand même bébé sont
couchés n'ont encore pas d'accord que
oui non est-ce que par amour irène vous
accepteriez de fréquenter des clubs
échangistes alors un club d'échangé
c'est quand tu fais quelque chose avec
plusieurs genres en même temps c'est ça
non c'est pas mon c'est parce que j'aime
faire non j'ai jamais fait le nom ça
m'attire pas ouais tu peux le voir
plusieurs fois qu'une personne
différente et comment vous faire
plusieurs fois il l'avait versée
comment vous savez que ça vous plaît pas
parce que vous avez jamais ce que j'ai
jamais pensé parce que quand je suis
avec quelqu'un j'aime bien moi je vous
explique enfin j'étais ce flicage pin's
et d'attention à ces héros car le haut
non moi c'est le moi c'est le feu moi
c'est ça l'amour c'est la merde ses
dessins sur le sable c'est le bon moi
c'est tout ça avec quelqu'un oui donc ça
me comble enfin ça m'attire pas bien en
cas les clubs échangistes
pourquoi pas par amour en cas tulle m
qu'ils sachent ses plaies six années
j'ai dit la nuit
il ya une très bonne tenue dans ce débat
et oui les clubs échangistes pareil je
déteste partager partage pas faire
l'amour avec son meilleur pote non pour
lui faire plaisir
sinon vous avez d'accord est-ce que par
un mois où seriez prête tapotage hockey
par aman je serai prête à faire tout ça
sur une autre planète mais sur tel jeu
venir
irene est ce que vous seriez prêtre par
amour à devenir son esclave sexuelle
bien sûr en permanence partagez-la
plaisions notre secours elles discutent
ou kewell paramo vous soyez prête à
devenir son esclave sexuelle non par
amour et rennes est ce que vous seriez
prête à changer de sexe
mais moi je m'aime moi je suis vous
l'avez pas tellement tellement tellement
une femme je pourrais pas pour rire un
petit peu mettre un gode ceinture mais
tâchons de sexe la nage encore me
changer de sexe non ok oui s'il prend le
bien de seconde
essayons si ça ne plaît pas tout me
redonne
cette année
les choses ont changé de sexe ou non
lignum van nhon j'entends maintenant on
va faire l'inversé
patrick bruel si vous deviez choisir une
des modèles ce laquelle prendriez michel
fils patrick haas est très difficilement
l'idée ben moi aussi moi là moi aussi
non mais c'est un jeu je trouve que
cueillir elle a quelque chose de très
touchants dans sa tendance à dans sa
vérité est très passionné
[Applaudissements]
mais ça
l'astre avec des vrais ça c'est tout est
vrai ici il ya hockey a fait ça sur une
autre planète exo wagon wheel patrick
quand même ce serait plutôt iran mais
j'attends qu'elles sont charmants toutes
les 3 c'est pas qu'on dit c'est toi on
attend qu'on s'engage l'échelle d'après
qui toi julie et dans les coulisses je
t'emmerde
julie n'était pas dans les coulisses
michel
je n'ai aucun cadre jean-luc irène
baffie je me ferai une belle brochette
de couchage pour les 3g c'est beaucoup
vexé v 2 août mais je prends aussi
rennes
[Musique]
et
mais bon voilà
pour savoir si kim mérite de remplacer
en cas on va comparer vos réponses avec
celle d'en cas dans l'interview
kim est ce que par amour vous seriez
prête à vous déguiser en elton john ah
oui comme encas incroyable qui mus que
par amour vous seriez prêt ça vous
droguez non comment cas est-ce que par
aman vous auriez prête à prendre 17 kg
qu'est ce qu'elle a répondu en cas
marche pas comme ça
comme qui me l'a dit
alors est ce que vous seriez prête à
prendre 17 kg pas mon nom quand mon cas
est ce que par aman vous seriez prête
attention
tapotez vibre à limoges
parce que dit avoir tu vas tu es un con
facile donc la réponse est dans mon cas
oui mon cas c'est incroyable c'est un
clown vraiment est-ce que par amour vous
seriez prête à cacher quelqu'un qu'il
vient de tuer par amour une femme oui
comme encas d'ailleurs je crois que là
on assiste vraiment à un sans faute je
pense que les a pas de est-ce que par
amour vous seriez prête à embrasser cent
fois ses chaussettes sales non cinq
comme en quarts en cas répondu le mec
qui me demande ça il dégage tout de
suite oui c'est marrant car c'est son
côté elena ceausescu est très est-ce que
par amour vous seriez prête à fréquenter
les clubs échangistes
non vraiment cas c'est incroyable c'est
vraiment on m'a alors est-ce que par
amour vous soyez prêtes et devenir son
esclave sexuelle
peut-être à beaucoup mieux okah avait
dit non bien bien elle est mieux vue
d'accords sexuelle c'est bien c'est vrai
que dans la chanson c'est important
est-ce que par amour ou seriez prête qui
m'a accepté quelques infidélités mais on
touche la cible par amour tu voulais
mairie sa peau si ça peut commander un
réseau de le coupe oui pourquoi pas on
sent la différence entre la vietnamienne
et la roumaine c'est à dire qu'en cas
avait répondu jamais et vous vous êtes
prêtre c'est bien vous êtes plus maligne
c'est bien j'ai tout compris vous allez
garder longtemps votre thierry ardisson
gisèle billes on va voir si vous avez
une chance de former une famille sur les
terres bio et vitraux
donc la toile et par amour les habitués
connaissent un grand classique de
l'émission ce que par un mur je crois
que ce soir ça s'impose
est-ce que par amour vous êtes prête à
cacher quelqu'un qu'il vient de tuer eux
n'ont pas ce que j'aurais peur qu'ils ne
tuent voyez enfin je veux dire vous êtes
apte à tuer quelqu'un qui vient gâcher
j'ai des problèmes avec le crime je
pense que même toi tu vas la première
question répondent ont déjà c est ce que
vous êtes prêts notamment julie delpy à
vous mettre aux drogues dures
non si vous êtes prêts est ce que vous
êtes prête à prendre 17 kg par amour bah
oui c'est le poids d'un bébé
est-ce que par amour alors là c'est
évidemment la question clotilde courau
qui a épousé cette semaine la question
la princesse avis la question de la
française s'est lui les princes de
venise et quand il avait lancé son
parfum tu l'avais dit qu'il était tête
de gondole du tibet et bien voilà c'est
plein de souvenirs qu'on a on leur
souhaite beaucoup de bonheur aux deux
tourtereaux
est-ce que donc comme clotilde courau
vous seriez prête à embrasser cent fois
ses chaussettes sales mais pourquoi je
ferais ça par amour on choisit pas vous
savez mes salles de basket salle de
chaussures en cuir de prince avec des
chaussettes voir des donc
alors au waf ouais vraiment voit la
belle julie moi je me poserai plus la
question après cette unité nous vous
refusez tous et non non non j'ai dit oui
les chsld aller mais oui mais au bout du
bout des lèvres les ars comme ça oui
comme ça bon alors est-ce que par amour
vous accepteriez julie quelques petites
infidélités
si moi aussi je peux être infidèle oui
sans problème un sens à ma connaissance
non est-ce que vous accepteriez par
amour qu'il a une maîtresse
ça oui ge
moi ça ne pose pas de problème mais vous
avez trouvé la salle est pas chiant
c'est bien la fidélité est une chose qui
me semblent abstraites en fait dans un
couple l'un du rayon de quelque chose
sur la mecque pour les deux amants pour
les deux c'est déjà plus un bébé tu
étais comme certain jean-jacques toi
dans ton couple vous acceptez les non
pas d'un fil et non non non sûrement pas
non tu es capable de tuer un chasseur
s'il faut 7 discret je pense mais est-ce
que par amour vous seriez prête à vivre
à trois avec sa maîtresse
sympa la maîtresse a amusé en fait la
vaisselle fait le lit de toussaint pas
vraiment la maîtresse cool mais déjà je
sais pas si j'accepterais de vivre avec
la personne parce que la main le mec
déjà j'aimerais mieux qu'ils ceux qui
vivent ensemble à quelques mois j'ai un
appartement séparés et voiliers pour moi
ça me conviendrait mieux à deux avec la
maîtresse non pas du tout si c'est juste
une copine oui c'est très dérangeant
mais non non non non j'aimerais mieux
être seule en fait si la somme il peut
aller avec sa maîtresse yves avec sa
maîtresse à me dérangerait pas des
propos un chien t3 moi je compatis avec
l'abbé changistes par amour ah non non
ça non bon mais j'étais tout seul non
les clubs échangistes ya quelque chose
d'un peu cradingue quoi le côté des gens
qui se connaissent pas se taire par tous
il faut connaître les gens d'où ils
viennent
quelles sont leurs formations sinon je
suis pas du tout par tous dans ça n'a
rien du tout est-ce que par amour vous
seriez prête à devenir son esclave
sexuelle
c'est quoi une être une esclave sexuelle
magnéto bon oui pendant quelques temps
quand même temps j'ai pas quelques mois
mais après faut que ça passe parce que
j'avais à vous d'être resté à toute
votre vie ah non non non ça non c'est
pas possible non c'est mal barré très
mal barré dernière question je suis
passé au poignard et est-ce que par un
mot vous seriez prête à vendre votre
corps pour lui non
obligés de prêter à rien pour rien vous
avez vos questions c'est pas ici des
questions de la vie et vous je peux
retourner qu'est ce que vous êtes prêts
à vendre votre corps par amour ouais
mais si ma femme et je refais un serment
solennel sociale oui ma femme me demande
de vendre mon corps par amour je le fais
ok de baiser avec je sais pas si à
sarkozy par exemple à s'arrêter si ma
femme me demande je passais beau quand
même l'amour voilà il est pas mal enfin
[Musique]
interview par amo et scott amour il
seriez prête à vous déguiser en elton
john ont bien sûr ouais c'est pas si
compliqué j'ai déjà la couleur de
cheveux est-ce que par un mot vous
seriez prête à cacher quelqu'un qu'il
vient de tuer c'est possible c'est
possible oui ça pourrait faire un bon
début d'histoire de traînards d'ailleurs
c'est possible oui bien sûr les manuels
c'est son truc à elle vous soyez prêtes
à vous mettre à la drogue
non non non et à prendre 17 kg ça m'est
arrivé au oui par amour si on veut qu'il
dit je t'aime avec 17 kilos en plus vous
le faites bien sûr ça n'a jamais empêché
de prendre deux jours
est-ce que par un mot vous seriez prête
à accepter quelques infidélités
c'est possible ah oui oui je comprends
que vous soyez caser sa lune son jeu 10
ans mardi
non c'est possible vous accepteriez
qu'il est une maîtresse par aman ça
dépend ce qu'on entend par maîtresse une
année avec laquelle il toucherait de
temps en temps oui ça vous dérange pas
je sais pas peut-être que si c'était de
temps en temps souvent ça me dérangerait
puis se défoncer par gens qui savent pas
non l' importance et quand l'un des deux
trompe l'autre c'est que le reste du
temps ça se passe bien à la maison mais
souvent quand l'un des deux troncs quand
il revient il fait la gueule
voyez tout le proche parce qu'on voulait
c'est que je me laisse et andrew ladd et
en et rentre à la maison elle est plus
heureuse et qu'elle rend plus heureux ou
qui les rend plus heureux de ça ça suis
heureuse ça ne pourra pas mais si c'est
pour faire la gueule parce qu'il
culpabilise qui rejette tout sur l'autre
comme ça arrive très souvent non vous
vous y connaissez
qu est-ce qu apparemment prêtes à vivre
à trois avec la maîtresse j'avais fait
un film là-dessus et gazon ça je sais je
crois pas que ça puisse marcher nord je
crois pas que ça puisse marcher à long
terme
je parie que samedi à des couples et
pour qui ça peut marcher parce que c'est
sous toujours le mec qui est chef parce
que le mec élevé quand même polygame
london polydyam de nature la femme étant
monogame donc c'est emmerdant coin et
les clubs échangistes par amour ah non
non non est-ce que par amour vous seriez
prête à ne plus jamais faire l'amour
demande apparemment woodham énorme
problème qui peut arriver il a sauté sur
une mine ou un truc comme ça ça peut
arriver non cotées
je regarde comme ça mon regard tombe sur
toi sans aucune intention malveillante
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
changer de sexe c'est pas penser à ça
j'ai réfléchi c'est à dire que c'est le
coup samedi mais bon je me suis donc
auquel on pense c'est ça qu'on décline
ses 30 ans atteint les jours en dix ans
à ses services publics c'est amener des
gens à la réflexion découvrir de
nouveaux territoires déchets aux
acadiens j'avais pensé à changer de sexe
josiane je rencontre un homme me dis je
t'aimerai tellement mieux si tu étais
voilà qu'est ce qu'on ferait greffer un
pénis et ça voudrait je voudrais pas
rentrer des tests voudrait dire qu'il
faudrait que le pénètre oui mais est-ce
qu'on a besoin de le faire greffer
c'est édité chez fayard matin il a lu
par amour
[Musique]
kamel ouali est ce que par un mot vous
seriez prêt à vous déguiser en elton
john à fond ah ouais est-ce que par un
mot vous seriez prêt à prendre 17 kg
n'ont apporté des nattes
ouais ouais deux petites nattes blondes
sapin ouais pour une journée est-ce que
par un mot vous seriez prêt à vous
mettre aux drogues dures avec des
n'atteint toujours à quitter la star ac
oui ah ouais ouais je crois de choses
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prêt à
ce qu'elles commettent quelques
infidélités
cela énerve déjà quand on aime quelqu'un
on a envie que cette personne soit
heureuse du moins sexuellement avec moi
alors elle n'est pas d'accord il est un
peu alors quand même est-ce que par
amour
vous seriez prêt à vivre à trois avec
son amant sûr que non sûr que non la cjv
possible elle et tous les trois dans un
club échangiste non plus pour un tifo
pourquoi
ouais ouais bah oui il est prêté à gpa
temps non non non attention on peut être
juste voyeur tu me débecte vous seriez
prêt d'une année ce claf sexuelle pas
vraiment avec beaucoup de mal mais
jamais été esclaves sexuelles c'est à
dire des trucs là tu cherchais un mec
bras très belle dans la lah ariel on va
rester dans les femmes et l'amour on va
faire une interview par amour
[Musique]
arielle dombasle est ce que par amour
comme si si vous présenteriez des
maîtresses à votre mari eh bien écoutez
je ne sais pas mais si c'était le seul
moyen de le garder peut-être que je le
ferai que ce beau mais également non
mais vide alors là je n'ai aucune
réponse à m
[Musique]
oh que c'est beau mais évidemment je
voudrais toujours être là favori enfin
j'en rêverai je rirais éloge de la
saison est-ce que par amour vous seriez
prête à cacher quelqu'un qu'il vient de
tuer
ah ben ça bien sûr le cacher oui bien
sûr bien sûr a pas de problème à mais
aucun problème et je dirais même ma
chute j'ai même nom mais je dirais même
que c'est moi qui l'ait tué harry mais
on le trouve une magnifique île à une
chanteuse à l'envers c'est le plus vert
de la banque
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
vous mettre à la drogue ou l'arrêter
je dirais que je serai tout pour d'abord
en dissuader lundi connais mais je crois
que par amour on est prêt à tout
d'ailleurs
moi je me souviens voyez dans dans mon
enfance où j'habite et le mexique
alors je me rappelle que mon père avait
fait prendre des champignons
hallucinogènes à ma mère est donc
finalement oui bien sûr je n'ai pas de
mes causes et donc il est elle est là
elle avait essayé donc et je crois que
lui avait fait un trait merveilleux
voyage de champignons hallucinogènes et
elle par amour avait suivi et je pense
que ça c'était assez mal passé pour elle
voilà est-ce que par amour vous feriez
la laisser marianne
à votre avis est-ce que par un mot vous
seriez prête à prendre 17 kg oui bien
sûr mais bon si bernard henri penser si
bernard au rite en qui rigole ça va mais
nommés mais s'il avait envie tout à coup
d'une femme intègre une batterie voilà
un beau zéro il veut dire que c'est une
mauvaise eh bien je prendrai les 17 ou
l'eau mais je crois que c'est faisable
mais j'avais vu amiral j'avais vu quand
même à quel point les allées et dévoué à
son amour mais merde
c'est pas sûr que fait l'adaptation
féminine qui est sans doute
extraordinaire ariel est ce que par
amour
vous seriez prête à vivre avec bernard
et la maîtresse que vous lui auriez
présenter je sais pas j'ai j'ai connu un
cas où un homme vivait en effet avec sa
femme et sa maîtresse à la cave le dire
proche proche de vous oui des gens
connus non mais attends que des gens
proches de vous sérieusement en réalité
à un moment donné bon j'habitais le
mexique et mon père était un très grand
séducteur très beau eu peur très beau
très beau et un moment donné mais
j'étais très enfants est très petit
alors je ne suis pas sûr j'ai capté des
choses mais peut-être pas vraiment mais
il y avait une femme qui était la
dernière se disait la dernière
descendante du dernier empereur aztèque
qui s'appelait saute schild qui était
une ravissante métisse aux cheveux tirés
en arrière extraordinairement belle et
qui habitait chez moi au dessus de ma
chambre d'ailleurs et ma mère était
vivante et donc je me suis toujours posé
des question de comment est ce que cette
femme vivait à nous poser votre mère l'a
accepté ça en fait je ne sais pas ouais
et donc est ce que moi je serai capable
je sais pas mais tout ça est en même
temps vous savez très très douloureux
c'est parce que on était très amoureuse
quand même bien sûr car et c'est bien
tout le
l'idée de cette interview séparemment
est-ce que par amour par exemple vous
seriez prête à vendre votre corps si
bernard henri lévy vous le demandez à
des qualités un attention alors je
dirais d'abord je ne suis pas achetable
ouais non quand on aura dit le prix
quel prix les mettra la banane est ce
que par amour vous seriez prête à ne pas
faire l'amour pendant trois ans alors
commence maintenant
renaud jobin ça c'est terrible parce
qu'en effet mais vous voyez quand on lit
les grands mystiques tu m'aimes et saufs
juana inés de la cruz
par exemple la fin je pense qu'on arrive
à un certain plaisir dans l'abstinence
aussi directrice mme à ce qu'on appelle
oui et je pense qu'il ya une forme
d'extase aussi d'un de désiré et de se
dire non je suis plus fort que mon désir
je ne je ne cède pas je reste comme ça
en maîtrise de moi-même trois ans real
quand même oui je sais c'est les deux
elle et moi non mais mais mais peut-être
qu'on arrive à une sorte de forme
d'extase de douleur aussi
ou alors tu peux passer en manuel non je
reviens rien où vous vous croyez vous à
ça vous voyez ce qu'elle dit là que
l'abstinence amène à l'extase amiral ça
serait quand même ça peut être une
satisfaction
nous ne sommes pas des animaux ainsi si
nous sommes des manigances pas ça du
tout le sera peut-être des mammifères
nous ne sommes pas des animaux est non
mais on peut aussi simplement fantasme
est très très fort et on est dans une
sorte de rêve éveillé dans l'imaginaire
et avoir une sorte de forme d'extase
les champignons toujours mais finalement
je me demande ce que vous êtes prête à
faire par amour pour un homme vous êtes
prête à faire beaucoup pour un homme
oui oui on va voir interview par amour
[Musique]
est ce que est ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à vous déguiser en
elton john oui avec les lunettes la
perruque et ouais ouais ouais
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
prendre de la drogue comme mais n'ont
elles non parce que gg peut pas aimer un
homme que me demande ça va s'arrêter
quand même est-ce que par amour
si votre trois mêmes les rues basses les
botero est ce que vous seriez prête à
prendre 17 kg botero ses 117 points 2
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête
en brasse et 100 fois les chaussettes
sales de votre mari ah oui oui c'est
bien est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête dans un hameau à
accepter quelques petites infidélités
mais juste un peu non non mr un peu non
non non vous pas rien à faire même pas
pas de maîtresse tout ça vous n'êtes pas
par amour mais si ça le rend heureux
si vous l'aimez mais non mais non mais
non mais moi j'ai pas aimé non comme ça
donc vous n'êtes pas d'accord pour vivre
à trois avec la maîtresse il n'y a pas
d'accord pour aller dans les clubs
échangistes avec la maîtresse il n'y a
rien à faire non même par amour mais non
est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à devenir son esclave
sexuelle bassa dépendent
vous n'êtes pas contre la baisse a
dépassé ce sera un traîneau ben oui je
les bancs de quoi si vous aussi vous
voulez mais vous avez vous demande ça je
trouve que c'est un peu une interview
stupide
je vous le disais au 609 m
entièrement d'accord c'est quand même on
ne demande pas on est on est une esclave
sans avoir besoin d'eux mais pourquoi
l'esclave un plus il ya des choses c'est
quelque chose que je sais pas moi
j'adore ça marche pas comme ça
virgin bien aimé mais j'aime bien aussi
peut-être je viens à peut-être je vais
bien un petit peu être soumise quand
même prendre fin en mai appâté qu'il ya
une chose a décidé d'être quelque chose
c'est une chose
voilà ça c'est un autre type de jeu et
c'est une chose caution est un gie
quotient thalassa ça peut être aussi
drôle a pour un moment mais c'est moi
que j'ai dcid d'accord quand tu veux
mais pour savoir si vous êtes prête à
rencontrer l'homme de votre vie on va
voir ce que vous êtes prête à faire pour
lui on va faire une interview par amour
c'est
balitrand est ce que vous pourriez
passer s'ennuie en bas de chez votre
homme à l'attendre 50
est ce que vous pourriez vous convertir
à une autre religion sans y croire ah
non vous est difficile quand même comme
bella est ce que vous pourriez faire des
gosses sont les vouloir ah non si vous
répondez dans le secteur jamais trouvé
c'est pour ça qu'elle est ce un problème
est ce que vous voyez vous coiffer comme
catherine lara jusqu'à la fin de votre
carrière
4 m je ne sais pas comment il fait donc
il vaut mieux franchement il vaut mieux
elle ce courrier vous fâcher avec vos
parents par amour non mes parents sont
mais par amour de tes grands parents
est-ce que par amour pour les supporter
sa belle mère à la maison a dit clooney
ben oui vous êtes d'accord là-dessus ont
complètement là donc si la migraine
belle-mère un champ pourriez prendre 30
kg de plus par aman si je suis enceinte
oui d'accord
voyez vous m à la drogue par amant
qu'elle est enceinte oui est-ce que par
amour vous pourriez changer de sexe
n'ont jamais changé ça comment tu veux
dire cinq minutes cela mais maintenant
est ce que est ce que par amour vous
pourriez supporter des propos racistes à
la maison tous les soirs
vont ils supporter que la porte des
toilettes reste ouverte par amour non à
problèmes ah ça me dérange pas ça me
dérange pas au fond il supporte une
maîtresse vraiment deux maîtresses
non il supporte une caméra par amour un
mec qui aime filmer ses ébats amoureux
toilettes laissant la porte ouverte
nation est ce que vous pourriez
supporter un fouet pas un mot non
du coup de foudre non daniel quand elle
est couchée sur sa peau de bête devant
le feu de cheminée etc et patrick la
fois nécessaire et en même temps elle
est quasiment au score
est-ce que par amour c'est une balitrand
on pourrait supporter une ceinture de
chasteté
non adacore les clubs échangistes pour
garder oui pourquoi pas je suis jamais
donc je sais pas du tout pour le
surveillant est ce que par amour pour y
devenir son esclave sexuelle
or c'est très séduisant très consentante
il ya des trucs sur le cas des pavés au
niveau de la mer dit m seul attrapé très
bien et communaux on arrive à la pire
question maintenant aia
non la zapa daniel en effet céline oui
est-ce que par amour
vous pourriez supporter une toute petite
[ __ ] week-end déjà vous verrez bien
c'est ça votre disque s'appelant amor
amor vous ne serez pas étonné qu'on
fasse une interview amor amor ariel est
ce que par amour vous accepteriez de
jouer dans un film pornographique
si c'est bernard henry qui filme bon il
me filmerait avec amour
oui mais bon mais je je je suis d'accord
mais à une condition c'est que le film
ne sorte pas vous dire qu'il fallait
qu'on vient de voir le film chez vous
c'est est-ce que par un mot vous seriez
prête à vous m repassage oh ben ça bien
sûr ah bon oui oui d'ailleurs quand
j'avais 12 ans il m'avait donné un petit
air fer à repasser et j'adorais brûler
les trucs avec sa fille fer à cheval
mais là oui si c'est turbo vapeur et
tout ça fait quoi comme question il
s'appelle ariel pour sa bulle ou par
amour y avait ce que vous seriez prête à
mettre une autre fille dans votre lit
l'autre fils et moi je peux jouer
plusieurs rôles à fait d'accord et un
autre garçon un beau garçon et un autre
garçon bas c'est lui
on est d'accord il est très fort aussi
c'est pas un mot est ce que vous
pourriez tromper bernard et henri
tromper mais s'il me le demandait je
pourrais le faire à
c'est vrai mais ça c'est toi la plaie
vite ça c'est une vraie femme n'aurait
alors mais ça c'est bien mais ça le
rendait ça le rendrait très malheureux
s'il avait envie de se faire du mal à
s'il avait envie de se faire très mal et
qui me le demander ah c'est beau ce
machin le feraient par amour est ce que
vous pourriez vous faire raser la tête
et je sais que c'est elle par monsieur
mais mais mais j'adore monsieur propre à
moi je le beaucoup moins parce que je
trouve qu'il a beaucoup de style avec
ses bus et on s'est tous fait par amour
est ce que vous pourriez accepter une
gifle à ben tout de suite par amour mais
bien sûr ça vous est une gifle par amo
est ce que vous pourriez quitter la
france pour toujours moi je la quitte
souvent déjà et pour toujours pour
toujours
ouais bien sûr mais jean loret la
nostalgie je serai chagrine mais je le
ferai par un mot vous pourriez vivre à
mulhouse à mulhouse
oui attendez à rien avant de dire oui tu
allais à mulhouse arrière tous un
nouveau pas un clair de lune à mulhouse
c'est salon semo gauche c'est morano est
ce que vous pourriez renoncer au sexe
par amour et par aman ça c'est quand
même très très difficile quand vous
aimez un type qui peut plus voilà oui je
le ferai comme com com com comment dire
comme une sorte de mystique de l'amour
une privation absolue qui me ferait
d'accord mais au bout de 15 jours
ben je me roulerait par terre je serai
mais mais je serai un havrais j'entrerai
dans une sorte de dolorisme ça peut être
beau remarquer wee cc sauf juana inés de
la cruz sainte-thérèse
davila l'extase de sainte thérèse il
paraît que si on est dans l'abstinence
totale on arrive à des extases bon ça
intéresse elle crie quand on abaissera
par amour
si vous pourriez vous prostituées ah si
bernard vous le demande bien sûr ben oui
j'irai
oh là là mais bon je sais pas ce que ça
donnerait je sais pas vous y pensez des
fois j par essence et 32,9 à pomper
épopée promener dans rome la nuit comme
ça elle s'offrait à tous les hommes là
on entre dans des choses qui sont très
scabreuse moins scabreuses que par amour
vous pourriez arrêté de tourner des
films et christian clavier
mais bernard henri m christian clavier
ah oui oui le trouve très sympa je
pourrais m'arrêter de tourner des films
bien sûr ce n'est avec christian clavier
mais j'aime beaucoup christian clavier
mais bien sûr j'arrête
vous aimez les films de christian
clavier mais oui bien sûr jacquouille
tout ça mais tout le monde les a posées
pour sa part à mort et ce courrier vous
mettre au tricot
ah ouais ça je trouve très sensuelle une
femme qui tricotent non mais c'est vrai
un point à l'endroit un point à l'envers
à ramot où est ce que vous pourriez
changer de sexe ariel mais j'aurais pas
envie parce que parce que je trouve que
être une fille c'est fantastique c'est
vraiment mal astoria une fille quand
même pardon vous resteriez une fille
quand même vous auriez un sexe d'homme
par amour ah mais vous voulez dire que
je serai comme ça même un faux dit
voilà pourquoi t'as garder tes fiches
sur amanda lear
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pascal est ce que par amour du prochain
vous pourriez coucher avec une femme
âgée oui c'est un problème sans problème
est ce que vous pourriez coucher avec un
homme ça c'est bien s'il le fallait je
pense qu'en prison dans des conditions
spéciales de la sexualité se portent sur
tous les objets part de chez nous et
malbrunot là tout à l'heure j'aurais dû
lui dire en face aux enjeux est ce que
vous pourriez coucher qu'une mineure
apparemment du prochain une femme qui
travaillent dans les mines
l'instrument je le faire non là non la
scène avec une prostituée et pas de
problème oui avec une mini jean beast
comme paul mccartney va peut-être pas
mais mon héros pour le ferait voler avec
une fille très très très très très moche
oui pas de problème si très très très
très très salll j'ai pas la bc laon là
on a une à chaque forme ans il sait pas
il hésite avec une fille très très très
très conne alors oui ça sans problème
non parce que c'est pas si vous
l'acceptez alors là c'est est ce que
vous pourriez coucher avec une fille qui
dit malgré que à la place de bien que
oui parce que moi je le dis aussi 10
contre 10,2 qui dit par contre au lieu
de en revanche par exemple pourriez y a
pas de problème non ça c'est pas c'est
pas mal oui tu sais qu'on dit pas on dit
pas par contre marie l'eau elle savait
pas m'arrêter en seconde
kevin thomas non tu vas trop loin je
sais voilà c'est dur bon d'accord avec
un travesti
oui avec un vieux pote un peu bourru non
non non pas une usine ipod cousine
pascal un peu bourré ou wii prend pas
d'argent oui avec votre belle mère s'est
déjà fait ensuite la là vous me posez
une question people non non non je vais
dire non et bien qu'elle soit une très
belle très désirable est-ce que vous
allez coucher avec moi je préfère éviter
mais s'il le faut en prison dans votre
livre relié à vous vous évoquez vos
relations tumultueuses avec vos quatre
maris c'était toujours très très mal
terminée il soit dans la démence selon
l'hystérie quatre caisses quatre sont
vivants tous les quatre oui ils vivent
ensemble dans une satellite
on va voir ce à quoi vous seriez prête
par amour on va faire une interview par
amour
est-ce que par amour
est-ce que par amour vous accepteriez de
vous couper les cheveux
non non est-ce que par un mot pourriez
vous mettre au repassage
j'aime j'aime ça même sans abri d'accord
est-ce que par amour
vous pourriez arrêter votre carrière non
j'étais par amour vous pourriez vivre
sans sous vêtements
non ça à oui c'est vrai je fais l'amour
dans une chose comme il soldes je ne
sais pas de plonger
ah bon est-ce que par amour pour y
renoncer au sexe non est-ce que par
amour pour les remplacer de sexe par la
nourriture
non est-ce que par amon pourriez faire
l'impasse sur les préliminaires world is
a mean
et nice n'ont non je traite à fait rien
du tout par amour vous avez du mal
4 mariages et d'avoir du mal à trouver
un cinquième maria a maintenant il sait
tous ilian 5e y voit savoir est-ce que
par amour vous pourriez accepté de jouer
dans un film pornographique non par
amour
non si vous l'aimez non mais vous
l'aimez vraiment mais vraiment nous ça
nous ferait plaisir
alors d'accord
est-ce que par amour vous accepteriez
des gifles watts hermine non non
est-ce que par amour vous pourriez vivre
à seattle 6 watts in seattle
ouais non latins c'est une ville cette
ville du tout l'air d'être l'enfer
est-ce que par amour vous pourriez
changer de religion
ah non changez de secte est-ce que par
amour
vous accepteriez une autre fille dans
votre lit c'est what quelqu'un qui
voudrait le gazon dans la balance
non non non non mais vous n'êtes rien
attendez vous acceptez rien d'être date
soit yolande pièces non est-ce que par
un mot vous pourriez accepter un autre
garçon dans votre lit jack est enfin
attaquer les animaux est-ce que par
amour vous pourriez dire des choses un
peu sale en faisant l'amour midi le oui
alors quoi jeter par amour pour les
relancer à tous vos amis
non si c'est le vrai le vrai amour c'est
le sait le moi si je cherche quelque
chose c'est le même
alors on relance rien parce qu'on est
vraiment amoureux est-ce que par un mot
pourriez changer de sexe ya un
weah
[Musique]